mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs vous
allez assister cet après midi et ce soir
aux premiers programmes diffusés par la
seconde chaîne de télévision monsieur
robert bordas directeur général de la
radiodiffusion télévision française vous
parle
eh bien nous y sommes les dates sont
tenus voici le premier spectacle de la
deuxième chaîne
le programme que nous vous proposons
n'est pas celui d'une journée ordinaire
de la seconde chaîne
en effet les émissions que nous allons
vous présenter ne sont pas
nécessairement complémentaires de celles
diffusées dans le même temps par les
émetteurs de la première chaîne nous
commençons par du côté de la musique